un gynécologue a été attaqué pour avoir
refusé d'examiner une femme trans ça
s'est passé dans un cabinet à Pau à la
fin de l'été la secrétaire explique
qu'une dame en transition et son mari se
présente à l'accueil après avoir pris
rendez-vous sur doctolib j'ai aussi tout
prévenu le docteur il m'a répondu je ne
m'occupe pas de ça il y a des
spécialistes à Bordeaux ou à Toulouse
mais sache que je l'aurais transmis mais
ils sont devenus très agressifs et m'ont
traité de transforme après cette
expérience le couple laisse un avis
Google très défavorable il a refusé de
recevoir ma compagne trans sa secrétaire
nous a jetée froidement je déconseille
plus jamais ce à quoi le docteur Victor
acarien répond qu'il n'a aucune
compétence pour s'occuper des hommes
même s'ils se sont rasés la barbe et
viennent dire à sa secrétaire qu'ils
sont devenus femmes cette réponse lui a
valu une kyrielle d'insulte ce week-end
c'était loin d'être ma volonté je ne
suis pas transphobe ni homophobe j'ai
d'ailleurs aidé beaucoup de mes patients
d'homosexuels à avoir un enfant j'aurais
pu recevoir cette personne lui faire
payer la consultation de 80 euros pour
lui dire que je suis totalement
incompétent est-ce cela qu'elle voulait
ces personnes sont sous traitement
hormonaux prescrits par des services
spécialisés je leur laisse le soin de
les contrôler l'association stop
homophobie s'apprête à déposer plainte
et l'association Espace Santé trans elle
assure que les gynécologues ont vocation
à suivre des femmes trans même sans
opération de réassignation génitale et
même sans hormone mais selon le
professeur Philippe de Ruelle
gynécologue au CHU de Montpellier la
prise en charge des personnes trans
nécessite de ces former pour éviter que
les gens s'inscrivent au hasard sur
doctolib il serait mieux qu'au sein de
chaque région il y a des praticiens qui
choisissent de se sur spécialiser en
France on estime qu'il y a entre 20000
et 60000 personnes transgenres et entre
2012 et 2020 le nombre de demandes de
prise en charge de chirurgie mammaire et
pelvienne de réassignation ont été
multipliées par quatre
[Musique]